>> AND OUR JOONAS KORPISALO.
FIRST START OF THE SEASON FOR
THE 27-Y
BLACKHAWKS, HAD A SHAKY START TO
THE E E YEAR AFTER.
THREE FIRST ROUND PICKS FOR HIM,
THEYS PRETTY GOOD.
IN GOES ROSLOVIC.  HERE THE WOR
AHEAD FOR CHINAKHOV.
DIDN'T GET
MAKE AND A COUPLE OF SAVES HE
SHOULD NOT AND THAT'S WHAT
GREISS DIDH LAINE,
COULDN'T GET ANYWHERE.   SAVE B.
>> Mickey: NDS BACK THEN.
WHAT DO YOU REMEMBER ABOUT MIKE
SILLINGER YOU PLAYED WITH FOR
HE'S DOING RECONSTRUCTIVE
SURGERY AND HE'STHAN HIM.
>> YEAH, A MINUTES.
>> BECAUSE NICK IS UP HERE.
>> PUTTING PRESSURE ON THEM NOW.
>> SO
OH, THERE'S NOTHING LIKE A POWE
PLAY WITH 60 SECONDS LEFT IN I
DRIVE THE
FABBRI
BUILDING ALL E.
LARKIN, .   HIM WITH TWO
SECOND ROUND PICKS IN THE RYAN
NOW.
HERE IS LARKIN.
THEY WERE OUT THERE ON THE FIVE
AND THREE, THERE'S A SEIDER.  K
AT THE PLAY BY SEIDER.
BACK INSIDE THE ZONE AT HISR
FIVE.
YOU HEARD NICK COMPARE HIS AGE
TO SEIDER'S AND LARKIN,
AGAIN, THIS IS ON THE RUSH.
LARKIN AT THE BLUE LINE,POT
AND THE HIGH SLOT.   UNDER THE O
MAKE I QUICKLY TO
LEDDY.
AND S
NET.
FRONT.
AND LOOSE PUCK WITH AN EMPTY NET
GOAL.
GAINED CENTER ICE AND THENTEAM Y